eight on your side tonight despite
rising inflation and mortgage rates the
housing market in las vegas is still red
hot but home buyer optimism is the
lowest we've seen since 1978. we connect
with a local real estate expert who
shares what the market is doing now and
why he says you shouldn't be afraid to
buy
the las vegas housing market is very
competitive sellers getting multiple
offers some buyers waiving contingencies
last month nearly 60 percent of homes
sold above their listing price we are in
a strong seller's market but kirby
schofield of schofield realty says just
in the past week he's seeing home
inventory starting to normalize slightly
we've seen an increase in listings which
is good we're about a month of inventory
giving buyers a better chance of finding
a home what impact has rising inflation
and mortgage rates had on the market
about a quarter of the buyers surveyed
by redfin are moving up their home
buying plans hoping to buy a home before
inflation and mortgage rates increase
even more scofield says 30-year fixed
mortgage rates in nevada have hit an
average of 5.37 percent even sellers are
being affected by inflation many
choosing to sell sooner hoping to cash
out on their homes to help combat rising
costs you kind of get the perfect market
as a seller you're getting the sell side
you're still not losing value like it's
not short sale
foreclosure market but you're also able
to get
those buyer side benefits now that are
going his advice for first time home
homebuyers if you find a house and it's
affordable make an offer it's kind of
like waves
uh you've been waiting for that wave and
you've been missing them if you see a
good wave take it don't be greedy don't
sit back now and think oh now i'll take
the next one because the house may be
gone or the rates may
go up too high past your affordability
and if your budget is tight now due to
inflation maybe lower the price range
you're looking at because houses are
still typically selling for thousands of
dollars over asking price christian